this is Startalk this is from Mike
drawers my question pertains to the
potential human offspring on Mars has
there been any research done regarding a
child's physical development in an
environment so different than ours even
if we manage to terraform Mars we'd
still be living in different
gravitational conditions what would that
do
yeah so our body has evolved for earth
gravity ok so what's interesting and I
don't think we have the answer to this
is if you're born in 40% gravity and you
spend your whole life in that gravity
where you come back to earth right will
the body say oh thanks I'm back to my
own one g-force and or will it say whoa
this is not good it's terrible
this is terrible now we can't crushing
under my own weight we kind of do that
when you send an astronaut in zero-g for
a year and they come back to earth right
okay we already know the effects of
lower gravity your bone density drops
and other things and then they come back
to earth and they don't die well that's
not right you know so so I remain might
not be as bad as you think but now with
that change I mean this is a biological
question yeah but would that change over
time through adaptation so that so we
come back to Earth after being in zero-g
and your body always seeks an
equilibrium okay so that's why we go
back okay so I got a straight something
out right right right straighten
something out right here life does not
adapt uh-oh wait a minute no one for a
second no no life form ever adapt okay
anything okay see now I have to see my
whole mind it's going blank because I've
got to change the way I think about
everything right now adapt ssin implies
that you're in one environment and then
you go to another one and then you're
physiologically adapt to it okay that
know that so does not happen what
happens is in the genetic variation of
any generation
right some people have certain
properties that others don't
okay correct okay you go into a new
environment and everyone does who does
not have the properties to survive dies
they are summarily removed from the gene
pool and the one person who had that
property in advance in advance survives
right and they so therefore they did not
adapt right they were fit to survive in
that environment
correct they were the fittest of
survival correct and so when the word
adaptation it's true in the broad sense
of a species right but there's no active
adaptation ever going on at all so you
go to Mars and you know you might grow
accustomed to it but you're not gonna
come by you know by Oh genetically
adapted right you're not gonna come back
with three fingers and antennae because
you need a tomorrow right unless you
came there with that started send the
three finger to intended people to Mars
they'll be just fine
fantastic all right yeah so I got 10
seconds left here so let me add
something else to this No
so it could be that on Mars sort of our
kind of people fail you don't mean black
people the most thank God thank God no
regular regular humans right as we
currently know ourselves doesn't work
out well on Mars but someone gives birth
to a kind of human that can breathe a
different mixture of oxygen or you know
a variation that is just natural in what
goes on and then they become the
dominant strain of the human species
there that's how you end up specie ating
right because then they have a variation
that's even better right and even better
and it leaves genetic mutations
eventually it's not an adaptation it's a
genetic mutation correct that happens to
be able to be good for that environment
and then you run it through and then
others die off and then you have just
speciated the human race swathe yeah
yeah and this is how you get all the
weirdest freaking creatures in Australia
really that's why you have like
marsupials I thought I was going to say
on Star Trek enough in Australia it's an
it really isn't a continent island
right that hasn't touched mainland it's
an in in millions of years and the
creature just do their thing that's so
funny so you have a species that is a
mammal where the baby is born outside of
the womb then crawls up into the paladin
and then you have the duckbill platypus
right lays eggs but it's a mammal
right that's how weird stuff happens
this is Startalk